las fuerzas de seguridad sudafricanas
utilizaron armas aturdidoras para
disuadir a las multitudes en
johannesburgo donde han tenido que
lidiar con turbas de saqueos como en
este centro comercial en su hueco ante
esta violencia las autoridades han
movilizado al ejército en los focos de
mayor tensión hard and sensing
underground is a los trolls of defense
la situación actual sobre el terreno
está bajo estricta vigilancia y nos
aseguraremos de que no se deteriore más
no podemos permitir que nadie se burle
de nuestro estado democrático y hemos
instruido las fuerzas del orden para que
redoblen sus esfuerzos para detener la
violencia y aumentar el despliegue sobre
el terreno
stop defense increased deployment on the
ground los disturbios en sudáfrica se
desencadenaron inicialmente por el
encarcelamiento del ex presidente jacob
zuma la semana pasada y ahora parecen
reflejar los problemas económicos
generalizados que se han agravado desde
el brote de coronavirus el presidente
del país se dirigió a la nación a última
hora de la tarde del lunes haciendo un
llamado a la calma snow ravens no hay
ningún agravio ni ninguna causa política
que pueda justificar la violencia y la
destrucción que hemos visto en partes de
iguazú natal y waterloo natal en how day
restableceremos la calma y el orden para
poder seguir con la tarea de reconstruir
este país y crear una vida mejor para su
gente
la policía ha detenido a cientos de
personas en las provincias de iwate en
iguazú luna tal y decenas de personas
han muerto durante los desmanes y creo
que es oportunista para otras personas
no puede ser el propio expresidente hay
otras cosas que se esconden detrás de
eso porque están saqueando las tiendas
porque se llevan cosas de las tiendas
esta frontera show se suma fue condenado
a 15 meses de cárcel por desacato al
tribunal al negarse a cooperar con una
investigación sobre la corrupción
durante sus nueve años en el poder la
semana que viene se enfrentará a otro
caso de corrupción relacionado con un
negocio de armas de dos mil millones de
dólares en 1999 cuando era
vicepresidente de sudáfrica